- That's a good one to get wrong.
That's a good piece of trivia.
That’s our Dilophosaurus.
A Rattlesnake?
Swans.
Swans?
Wow. The clicking?
That's pretty cool.
- So I'm going to say that was Blue.
Ayyy! Yay.
Okay.
That's good.
It's really tough.
Like, it's blowing out the
speaker a little bit.
So it could be the T-Rex or
the Indominus.
It's going to be one of those two though.
Oh, it’s the Indominus, yeah.
- I feel like instead of a baby elephant,
it would be like an
adult elephant, like, louder.
- I know with the Komodo Dragons
don't make a sound, though.
The baby elephants is right.
I'm going to call it as partially true.
- Oh, OK. Yeah.
Very tricky true-false question.
It would be an Ankylosaurus,
big spiky tail and the armor.
And it's just such a cool looking tank of a creature,
but it's got a little soft belly.
So you know that it's,
you know, it's kind and vulnerable.
- I think I would probably
have to say Diplodocus.
They're like the tall one with the big neck.
They seemed so friendly
and I even though they're kind of huge,
I don't think they'd eat me
because they're herbivores.
So my life would not be at risk,
which is kind of a pro
if you're going to adopt a dinosaur.